are you looking to migrate large amounts
of data between cloud storage buckets
but don't know where to start then stay
tuned this video is for you hi I'm Chloe
and today I'll be walking you through
the steps as well as some best practices
to transfer data quickly and securely
between object and file storage across
Google Cloud Amazon Azure on-premises
and more with storage transfer service
let's get started
[Music]
what your transfer strategy looks like
depends on the complexity of your
situation before you get started you'll
want to make considerations while
developing your plan
there are many options to consider when
transferring your data including
decisions around logging filtering as
well as considerations around deletion
versus overwriting for more information
on things to consider ahead of your
transfer including bucket naming
transfer speed optimization downtime
minimization metadata preservation
options versioned object handling and
more check out the documentation Linked
In the description below once you've
defined your transfer strategy it's time
to perform the transfer itself when
choosing a location for your storage
bucket you'll want to consider the
differences in availability price and
performance we've provided a link in the
description of a helpful table breakdown
of these options as well as information
on copying over bucket metadata
but for now let's show you how it works
you can copy objects from The Source
bucket to a new bucket using the Google
Cloud console the gcloud CLI rest API or
client libraries which approach you
choose depends on your transfer strategy
in this demo we'll be using the Google
Cloud console
to begin open the transfer page in the
Google Cloud console and click create
transfer job
[Music]
get started use Google Cloud Storage as
both your Source type and Destination
type choose a source either enter the
name of the wanted bucket directly or
click browse to find and select the
bucket you want
choose a destination either enter the
name of the wanted bucket directly or
click browse to find and select the
bucket you want
scheduling options you can ignore this
section for the purposes of this demo
batch is for single transfers or
recurring scheduled transfers while
event driven is a great option for
real-time migrations based on
notifications we'll select batch since
we're doing a one-time transfer
choose settings
select the option delete files from
Source after they're transferred
after you complete the step-by-step
walkthrough click create
this begins the process of copying
objects from your old buckets into your
new one
this process may take some time however
after you click create you can navigate
away from the Google Cloud console
if you'd like to view the transfer's
progress open the transfer page in the
Google Cloud console
once the transfer completes there's no
need to do anything to delete the
objects from your old bucket if you
select a delete Source objects after the
transfer completes during setup
you may however want to also delete your
old bucket which you must do separately
once you've confirmed that your data has
transferred and you've verified your
migration it's time to start using the
destination bucket you created
be sure to update any existing
applications or workloads so that they
use the new Target bucket name
you can check data access logs in Cloud
audit logs to ensure that your
operations are correctly modifying and
reading objects
once you've confirmed everything is
working well you can delete your
original bucket
you can also set up the option of
deleting objects after they have been
transferred or schedule object deletion
for step-by-step instructions including
information on our managed Cron job
scheduler in Google Cloud check out the
link in the description below
ready to get started transferring your
data learn more and see a full list of
our migration Solutions and services
offered by Google Cloud at the link
listed on the screen or check out the
description notes on this video for even
more resources to get started with
storage transfer service today
[Music]